[Music]
those of our soldier you're my dad
careful
come on let's go did you actually see my
Dad's life yes
we looked after each other hi Brothers
yeah kind of like brothers
James they're cleaning house you're
leaving the army with an honorable
discharge but you're losing your pension
and health care
we gave them our minds our bodies and
our spirit
chewed us up and spit us out
What You Did In Uniform Sledgehammer
[ __ ]
our thing scalpel works
we operate in a deep black OJ offshoot
with direct presidential Authority
Bank some decent cash put a down payment
on the house it's not dangerous now I
know you're lying maybe I need to take
care of my family so what do you say
you're down for the cause yeah
Salim Mohammed Moses study pathogenic
influenza viruses in humans we all know
what one motivated radical can do so
let's Cowboy Up Get it down and get home
to our families
understand what you're doing I'm trying
to save lives
it's only about money
[Music]
what do we do Mike
Brown BMW X1 comply I'll do that when
you confirm who you're working for you
work for me you gotta trust me I am
trying to help you oh we're working for
the president IAL Corporation
they train us to run their errands
kill their enemies and kill each other
foreign
he's gonna come after you with
everything he's got
[Music]
[Music]